love it or hate it the gaming world as
you know it today has in part been
defined by fortnite basically this
generation's goldeneye from grabbing
other games's best ideas and tossing
them into the battle royale to creating
a genuinely novel and distinct
experience that other games are kind of
desperate to emulate in this video we're
going to break down the biggest things
that fortnite pioneered and changed in
the gaming space like the vid sub to the
channel and whatever your feelings about
fortnite pay attention because we gotta
give credit to where credit's due
recognize this song
yeah this isn't today's battle royale
the little jimmy is getting hyped over
with his friends watching twitch streams
this is save the world fortnite's
original tower defense meets third
person hero shooter yeah fortnite wasn't
a battle royale in the beginning it had
a co-op campaign focused entirely on
crafting weapons and building and
leveling up these heroes
think a fusion of minecraft and left 4
dead now that's all you need to know
because not many people actually care
about this model but do you know what
was popular at the time though
winner winner chicken dinner
yeah everyone and their mother was
obsessed with the concept of battle
royale the popularity of pubg absolutely
caught the attention of epic games which
put out its battle royale mode a mere
six weeks after its early access launch
of save the world which is nuts fortnite
by design lacked a lot of the depth and
granular systems that pubg had now some
of the more hardcore folks might fault
fortnite for this but i think one of the
biggest reasons fortnite thrived
particularly for younger gamers was its
ability to be a simplified battle royale
you had a colorful map with distinct
areas like loot lake and pleasant park
you saw a purple or gold gun drop and
you just knew immediately what you were
looking for and there was also less
strain on your pc overall than in pubg
not to mention the console support
fortnite may have visually appealed to a
younger audience and had simpler
shooting mechanics but its building
system had a very high skill ceiling
which gave players a lot to master in
the early days new players didn't quite
understand building and they tried to
play the game like pub g often losing to
people who understood it
with its distinct art style and
increasing cultural relevance in the
early days i mean we're talking memes
and we're talking dance moves everywhere
that you turned combined with popular
personalities like ninja hopping into
the fray fortnite became a game for
everyone no one was excluded which is
rare as gaming can kinda be full of
gatekeepers
[Music]
now fortnite isn't the first game to
develop the concept of a battle pass
still it certainly led the way in
demonstrating what a good battle pass
should be to a mainstream audience other
leading live service games like
overwatch or destiny 2 doubled down on
loot boxes and microtransactions
the awful virtual currency models of
predatory microtransactions from
companies like ea or 2k were even worse
when it came to their sports games
fortnite on the other hand they struck a
solid balance by creating premium skins
emotes and gliders you actually wanted
to buy and also letting players earn
many of these cosmetics through the
battle pass not only that but the battle
pass included v-bucks the game's virtual
currency and it gave enough out for
players to earn the subsequency since
battle pass 2 so potentially some kid
who got like 10 bucks from their parent
could get every battle pass from then on
without really having to spend anything
else it's a brilliant loop over time
they have iterated on the battle pass
and have been willing to experiment
depending on each season the battle pass
would reflect that theme something that
i personally enjoyed there were themes
surrounding comic book characters and
marvel heroes and a season of warriors
from all over including the mandalorian
add on to the fact that a lot of these
skins that you would otherwise have to
shell out additional v bucks for they
were extremely limited time offerings so
everyone else wouldn't necessarily have
one and you could kind of show off what
you got still most of these skins felt
and looked premium softening the blow if
you had to shell out real cash whether
or not a premium skin is worth 10 to 20
dollars is totally up to you but i will
say this i'd rather pay that much for a
sick lighter skin with all the bells and
whistles but that's just me with
fortnite you effectively have the tools
to acquire a battle pass every season
for the foreseeable future not bad for a
game that is free to play
right fortnite smartly recognized that
purely pushing for victory royales
isolated its player base into many
losers and just a few winners the
isolation is real for every 100 player
server 99 players have to get their ass
beat right and the worst part of the
battle royale is having a bad match and
exiting around with minimal action not
everyone is ninja or tifu so the
solution was to give players more
opportunities to feel productive in
matches
even if they didn't get kills there's
still something to achieve almost like a
mini game inside each match enter the
seasonal challenges many of these
challenges were simple such as getting
several kills with a certain weapon or
simply dropping down into a named
location like tilted towers but there
were a huge range of activities golfing
basketball dancing in the right places
stunting in carts other challenges were
a little sillier like finding a piano on
a hill and playing a particular set of
notes
each week had a set number of challenges
and a hidden secret if you completed all
of the main ones that week you would
unlock a hidden banner that had a clue
in the image of where a hidden battle
star could be found now travel to that
area and search around and voila you got
a free battle star to help with your
battle pass and xp gains i gotta hand it
to them it was brilliant at times and a
fascinating way of giving players a
genuine reward for their playtime that
looped back into their battle pass
[Music]
so depending on which youtuber you
follow some will say that fortnite's
best ideas came from fans on reddit
whether that's true or epic came up with
this crazy time-traveling reality
warping plot has started with the masked
visitor on their own is up for debate
but fortnite has pioneered a living
story in creative ways
without going deep into a fortnite
history lesson fortnite started dropping
hints by adding interesting stuff to the
map and even in real life
like arg stuff maybe it was a bunch of
telescopes staring at a meteor in space
maybe it was a der burger in the desert
maybe a big purple cube that started
moving if enough players damaged it
across fortnite's servers you could
spend a game or two fascinated and then
shrug and move back onto your quest of
trying to get that victory royale but
then one time events started happening
and they caused huge ripples in the
community who took to the internet and
they all started speculating the story
didn't always go down perfectly for
example a very early event forgot to
protect players leading to the largest
kill record in any fortnite match when a
player knocked out the structure from
under a rocket viewing party of 48
players but the events kept coming with
the thing with the butterfly and the
time that huge black hole happened and
this whole thing with jonesy you know an
original default character that is now
suddenly a main story protagonist things
got pretty wild
the benefit to all this is that there is
now a narrative reason for changes to
fortnite which creates a fun way for
players to grow invested in the game
beyond the need to win now you had a
reason for why locations were changing
and the map constantly was updated and
that just made players pay attention
you're not into fortnite just because
you want that victory royale anymore
you're in a fortnight because it's cool
and you're doing different things and
there's a living story meme skins like
pili suddenly became fan favorites in
the storyline now it might seem minor to
some but creating a world in a battle
royale or any multiplayer game isn't
something that we should take for
granted but that's not an issue even if
you didn't care about the story you were
playing this limited time game modes or
events that kept popping up each season
and man were these game modes a doozy
now all these game modes that i was
talking about earlier some of these
involved broken and overpowered
mechanics such as an infinity sword that
was nearly impossible to obtain
seriously i spent an entire week before
christmas trying and failing to safely
secure the coveted infinity sword but
moving on who could forget thanos huh
arguably one of the most iconic gameplay
additions in the fortnite early days if
you secured the infinity gauntlet you
would turn into thanos and you could go
absolutely ham on anyone who tried to
challenge you there were seasons where
you could defeat marvel heroes and
villains in pve boss battles on the
island and you could even use some of
their powers other seasons had
interdimensional monsters that could
drop loot in high risk high reward
situations and as time went on the game
modes varied and weren't just do
different things in the battle royale
suddenly you had team deathmatch games
where you could respawn in 20v 20
skirmishes or a tomato versus a
durburger battle mode it was also a
robust community made section of fun
game modes or islands that players can
join some of them even being sponsored
by fortnite such as a skate mode back in
the day where you could try to collect
as many coins as possible while cruising
down a hill like city escape and sonic
adventure 2. then there's a party royale
a non-combat island where you just
hang out like you can take part in
little mini games you could chuck a
bunch of paint bombs at your friends you
could participate in fortnite's
laid-back live events and concerts i
mean they took things a step further
with its live service models by truly
going into uncharted territory and
putting out certain live events that
embraced celebrity and went nuclear
so these events are growing wilder and
they're more ambitious as the seasons
went on originally you might have had a
live event that involved unvaulting a
weapon based on the community's choosing
or maybe the marshmallow concert seemed
really cool letting you email it and
mess around with giant light shows that
filled your screen and it was the stuff
actually was really awesome these events
were fresh but the real bullseye that
caused the entire internet to pause and
admit okay this was sick was the travis
god astronomical concert without a doubt
both the dance moves and these events
started to take fortnite out of just
being a battle royale mode and it firmly
threw it into popular culture fortnite
by this point had learned from prior
live events and they began hosting
events in combat-free instances so
players couldn't really grief each other
they posted tweets warning players to
join early at a certain time to help
ease the service train and allow as many
people as possible to join the event
top it all off with the fact that the
events were absolutely nuts i mean these
visuals were electric the songs chosen
from travis scott in particular were
some of the mainstream hits sure to
resonate with the players who loaded in
and they even served as an incentive for
travis himself because the event teased
the brand new track opening a completely
new avenue of advertisement and exposure
for musicians and celebrities consider
this during the pandemic in particular
filmmakers and musicians started
dropping reveals or concerts in fortnite
forget a rave or a vegas residency you'd
get chris nolan showing off the first
trailer for tennant on a fortnight
theater screen and i promise you i am
not just raving but consider that these
reveals and concerts are happening in
fortnite and it is normal because this
sure as hell wasn't normal a few years
ago sure the game is sometimes a punch
line for most non-streamers over the age
of 16 but the haters aren't in on the
joke anymore the joke's on them because
they're missing out on all the cool
events that have consistently pushed the
envelope forward also epic took some
serious risks and they're experimenting
with fortnite that transition to chapter
2 is one of the best examples so during
season 10's live event fortnite shut
down its own game by creating this
in-game black hole all of its socials
went offline and logging into the game
only showed a silent black hole with the
option to exit the game the result the
world might as well have ended i'm not
even kidding people were going nuts
online and kids were losing their
goddamn minds driving their parents
crazy after 36 hours the game returned
triumphantly with a brand new map for
what epic called chapter 2. the event
was yet another reminder of fortnite
walking into territory that few other
games would even consider later on other
popular games would even take
inspiration and copy this example such
as destiny 2 shutting itself off before
a new season almost exactly like how
fortnite did it's also worth mentioning
that fortnite is particularly good at
taking other games best ideas and this
is not an objectively bad or good thing
it's just a fact apex introduced a ping
system for example and the ability to
respawn teammates and boom fortnite adds
those mechanics in like two weeks later
among us becomes a hit well fortnite
introduces its own among us mode as well
they're just so good at constantly
eyeballing industry trends and copying
positive elements from other games to
help elevate their own
consider for a moment that today one of
the things we reasonably expect now for
multiplayer games is cross save and
cross play functionality you know who
you can thank for that
yeah fortnight
like before fortnite sony in particular
was incredibly stingy about creating
this air of exclusivity this was sony's
bread and butter to be honest especially
since the ps4 was massively more popular
than the xbox one and sony quite frankly
had no interest in losing its lead over
its competitors therefore from a
financial standpoint it wanted nothing
to do with cross play for the longest
time sony did all of these pr gymnastics
trying to justify why it was so stingy
from claiming that they were doing it to
save the kids to general quality control
concerns all of these excuses however
proved to be moot when fortnite quote
accidentally threw the switch on
crossplay with xbox and nintendo openly
saying they would love to have crossplay
and sony being the only grouch in the
room pouting at the bargaining table
everyone's hand was suddenly shown and
players clearly saw who the bad guy was
what's wild is that the biggest reason
sony eventually caved on some games is
because of how ridiculously popular
fortnite was no other game was able to
twist sony's arm and bully them in such
a way to allow the ps4 and xbox one
crossplay to occur in particular and by
the end fortnite came out on top it
didn't just properly implement
crossplaying crosstalk for its own game
but it created a new normal for future
games to follow now big blockbuster
games like call of duty apex and destiny
2 have crossplay functionality with even
more games introducing cross progression
you know love it or hate it fortnite's
legacy is undeniable the game has pushed
the envelope forward from redefining how
a live service game should reward
players time and money to experimenting
with its own success all while using the
gobstopping revenue it's acquired to
incorporate huge celebrity events such
as concerts headlined by ariana grande
and travis scott to turn itself into
more than just a battle royale game it
has no issue with reworking its own
gameplay loop and it has painstakingly
crafted a living story that evolves with
each new season over time
trust me there were times when i was
just so over this game and i think it
can be overhyped and i definitely think
that it can be overrated but to deny its
accomplishments
that would ignore the reality gaming has
forever been changed by fortnite and in
many ways for the better
[Music]
you